last time on nostalgia critic Randy
Savage
Sega tongue and Don Bluth you can figure
out the resume
you
well I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't have to this is my
punishment for making fun of Don Bluth I
have to play dragons late it doesn't
sound that bad but have you ever
actually played dragons live of course
not nobody has you just watched it like
everyone else did and wait for that
eccentric millionaire to come in blow
all his money and figure out what moves
you're supposed to do okay here's the
thing the game really is innovative and
beautiful nothing had ever been done
like it before
what is friggin hard imagine Legend of
Zelda to Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and Silver Surfer blindfolded that is
only the training - how hard this game
is is someone regretting not talking
about how awesome I am you do know the
last time I did anything game related it
totally blew up in my face right yep I
really hate you right now
hey I need to do a death glare again you
know what try me I bet I've gotten used
to it by now
you're like that shaming disapproval of
every morbid grandparent less talking
more reviewing so if you don't know
dragon's lair came out as an arcade game
in the 1980s the story was what every
story was for a game in the 80s guy
saves chick but to be fair this one did
have a good sense of humor as both the
hero and the damsel seemed playfully
airhead ish it was the first
cinematically animated adventure quest
with Bluth as the director of animation
back then it was practically impossible
to replicate it on other platforms but
today it's been adapted to several
consoles and has been beautifully
updated but with that said it's still
fergan impossible now granted you can
set it to easy with the arrows always
tell you where to go but there's a name
for that I believe it's called um
cheating yeah the arcade game didn't
work that way so that's not what I'm
doing either I'm gonna play it as the
game intended the way that made it
popular when it first came out with that
in mind the controls are seemingly
simple up-down left-right and push one
button to use with a sword easy enough
right well here's the problem it's not
always clear what you're supposed to do
sometimes it's a no-brainer you see a
monster you use the sword but other
times you're supposed to move out of the
way how am I supposed to know to use the
sword on this monster but run away from
that one but so what I can just learn
from my mistake on the next turn right
11 herbs and spices are wrong you see
because this was a new kind of gameplay
the developers thought it might be too
easy so they change up the level so you
wouldn't figure it out too quickly
because of this you have to remember
what the right choice was ten stages ago
when it randomly pops up again because
every single stage needs to be defeated
sometimes twice in order to get to the
final level okay and that when I use the
sword only ones very important okay now
when I don't use the sword at all I jump
back putting it in the vault
what's wait a minute it was a glowy
thing how am I supposed to not go after
a glowy thing in a game it's a glowy
thing it's like telling a dog not to go
into a bone it's frigging nature no
we're back here again okay use the sword
illegal ah you're my bitch purple buddy
night
what that was - glowy things you just
got if I had not even gone to one call
we think they could give me fucking -
there's like I mean that's why I turn
cupcake then you give me two cupcakes
and they smack me in the face we're not
going after the two cupcake what do you
want in the depths of your ignorance
what do you want
mmm glowy thing
it said drink me the goddamn game give
me an instruction and it lied to me
I wasn't about to drink it even though
it said drinking who's running this
goddamn place GLaDOS sometimes they're
kind and cleverly layout clues brief
like whatever space is available that's
probably where you're supposed to go
once in a while even a door will open
and close to indicate that's where
you're supposed to head towards logical
deduction can be the obvious route but
even the directions can be a little
confusing like lookee here does this
count is down or left in the one
fraction of a second you have to have to
make a decision down now this one seems
pretty easy
give me a playa time to figure out which
way to go child whoa you're really bad
at this you think I can usually win this
in ten minutes
that's because you made it schmuck
actually there was more effort in this
layout then you may think I'm not a
gamer and so when it came time to doing
the game a young man named Rick Dyer
brought it to us and said I watches your
game about a little night that goes into
a castle and save the princess well the
whole idea the concept sounded good but
I didn't know how to do a game so the
entire game which is about 20 minutes
worth of animation is a threat resolve a
threat resolve the fun of the game was
showing how many funny ways a person can
die and go resurrect I do what to say
one of my favorite things is hearing
Dirk's wide variety of cowardly screams
they're heard more often when you play
shut up actually I wouldn't be shocked
if Roose Campbell was inspired by some
of dirts cries god this game is so hard
dammit and now the nostalgic critics top
11 death scene I'm not giving you the
pleasure number 11 number 10 number 9
make it this time memory I almost have
that number seven Oh dirty little sinks
you're not funny at all number five I
don't even my pain will not sustain you
through not even happen number two the
number one nostalgia critic death will
not be taking place cuz I just got to
the final level ah don't worry I'll save
it for a special moment yeah well I'm
about to win this sucker after Daphne
talk to me oh you saved me the cage is
locked with a key the dragon keeps it
around his neck too
slay the dragon use the magic sword
Heights on the bride's eyes on the prize
I thought the prize eyes off the prize
strangely enough the final level is
surprisingly not that difficult maybe
they finally want to show some friggin
mercy so to be fair that's more with
Dragon's Lair to it Dragon's Lair I am
warm this was a much better put together
gameplay that flashing light that only
gave direction once in a while is now
throughout the entire game the story is
still the same with Dirk saving Daphne
from an evil villain but luckily the
villain has a brother who happens to be
a time machine
well obviously trust me when I say
that's the lease of this games weirdness
it starts off when you see Dirk telling
his incredibly fruitful see that their
mothers been kidnapped again I guess
they kidnapped again idiot and the first
level is literally escaping your mother
it's pretty hilarious at first it looks
like you're just following them through
time as you drive by the prehistoric age
ancient Egypt and even the Garden of
Eden but then it gets really weird by
traveling to a giant Beethoven in a
flying piano and even wonderland
yeah like Alice in Wonderland it makes
no friggin sense but it looks amazing
was really again the slightly cold
the way vlog mimsy were the borogoves
and the mome Raths of me this is some of
the most imaginative imagery you will
ever see it again Don what the hell were
you smoking to even come up with these
weird-ass ideas you know Dragon's Lair -
was really fun for me because we didn't
have to stay in the same time zone and
we didn't have to stay in the same
location so it you know it just triggers
the imagination you can go into any
place that you can imagine with
animation anything is possible
the only downside is once again the game
developers were afraid this would be too
easy so they had a little trinkets and
treasures you're supposed to pick up
throughout the game port not a bad idea
until you get to the second-to-last
level and realize that if you missed
even one of those trinkets you have to
play the entire game again all over
collecting every single last one sort of
okay I play through once I can play
through it again let's get all those
items yah what the hell am I missing
it's gotta be dead what else is there oh
wait what'd I just do hold on are you
telling me that the butterfly is glowing
signaling me to grab it the exact same
time the fire is glowing the exact same
color wow it's like the extended cruelty
of the first game is condensed down into
one single solitary fuck you moment Oh
guess what fuck you moment fuck you
goddamn magic guys are easier to see
than that but whatever I'm down to the
final level I have to get the evil ring
off Daphne and kill the wizard before
she beats me and I only got one life
left to do it
yes there it is baby Baroness well it
only took me eight places of the entire
game but I finally won the damn thing
we're still going oh my god
you're making me play through my happy
ending I don't know what that's awesome
or awful it's awful okay almost there
almost there
Oh somebody happily ever after and that
is the number one nostalgia critic death
scenes are a pain they're beautiful and
amazing to look at better goddamn pain
I'm glad they're so groundbreaking it
innovative but they are impossible
they are so freaking frustrating and so
incredibly hard I'm Luna support
Dragon's Lair but only to watch it not
to actually play it isn't there any way
to do that without going through all
this torture well you could promote
dragon's lair by supporting our
crowdfunding campaign wait you mean you
are making Dragon Slayer movie yeah so
let me get this straight if we get this
funded we would have gotten dom blue V
Don Bluth one of the animation gods to
return to animation pretty much
I literally just orgasm the sperm that
looks like Littlefoot see there he goes
if you're gonna do it you have to do it
the right way right way what what's the
right way the most advanced video game
you can play is awaiting your discovery
hey you want to see this on the big
screen
uh-huh we'll make dragon boy or a movie
dragon slayer you need that awesome
arcade game we were just playing
no talking long talking yeah ready for
some excitement the main drag of viral
movie
dragons live fictional play there's only
room for one scream he's like a bath
around
ah Oh with your school PAPRICA suit
humming dragon's lair a movie or dawood
will give you the death steer
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out as you know next week
we're gonna have a link for an IndieGoGo
the dragon's lair movie but until then
as always I'm going to do a charity
shout out here and this is one that you
see all over the place usually outside
ringing a bell and by god they try their
hardest to do the best and as of course
the Salvation Army The Salvation Army
isn't just one cause it's several causes
it wants to help families it wants to
help adults it wants to help children it
wants to keep them fed it wants to keep
them in houses it wants to keep them
warm and safe it wants to help people on
Christmas and wants to get them food it
wants to do everything that has to do
with helping people every year around
this time you see them outside the
grocery store is the malls in the city
everywhere ringing that Bell in the
freezing freezing cold there has never
been a year you have not seen those
people they are always out there trying
their best reminding you of those who do
not have a place to go or do not have
much food to eat they do this because
they believe in helping people they
believe in making the world a better
place and they have done exactly that
time after time you can look at their
YouTube channel you can see so many of
the various things they do and of course
you can just go to their website but
even outside of that just donating the
tiniest bit outside the grocery store
the mall or wherever they are this is
the time of year when they need the most
donations so please definitely be
generous and make all those times that
they're waiting in the cold or if it